this is Jocko podcast number 215 with
echo Charles and me Jocko willing
good evening echo good evening you got a
little quote kicked things off today the
general who does not advance to seek
glory or does not withdraw to avoid
punishment but cares for only the
people's security and promotes the
people's interest is the nation's
treasure that's a little sunsoo coming
at you and of course we covered sunsoo
on podcast number 23 and you can it's
just always interesting how you can find
the same themes throughout time from a
leadership perspective I know I talked
about this this point a lot in
leadership strategy and tactics book
this statement right here is this 2500
years old and he's saying the same thing
that I say in leadership strategy and
tactics that many of the problems that
come about for a leader are from their
ego and so we have to learn to keep our
Eco in check now this is we talked about
it in extreme ownership the very first
book this isn't like hey I just thought
of this yesterday and it's not like I
just thought of this anyway so like I
said somebody was jumping on somebody
was was making some comments on on
social media platform that they said
he's acting like he liked me I'm acting
like I invented cover and move you know
you know I've of course I said hey no
it's actually I say all the time I
didn't invent this or much of anything
so I didn't invent this idea of ego I
didn't just think of it whatever but it
is a theme that we see over and over
again from people that pay attention
mm-hmm
not just from a leadership perspective
either I mean I'm we're talking life
problems so this was interesting so we
just wrapped up the jock alive too
it was awesome thanks for gonna came I
got some really good questions along the
way and a lot of times the questions
sometimes the questions are about ego
even though the person doesn't even know
that the questions about ego but when
you start to dig in you start to realize
that it's about ego but though so this
first question is one of those questions
and the question was something along the
lines of this it was something like what
should I do if a peer of mine is working
hard putting an extra effort and trying
to shine so that they get promoted that
was the question and that's a good
question right cuz right what do you do
and and the instinct is well like you
know I'm saying you can even feel that
it's tick I can see the look on your
face right now
yes you have the look on your face of
like you can see that that's a little
bit offensive right when you go oh this
person's trying to war a car trying to
put that extra effort and trying to
shine so that they can get promoted
right no one likes that person by the
way right no one likes the the
brown-noser yeah so we get it so then
the question was what should this person
do what you know that's the guy asked me
what do I do when that's happening and
the instinct which is the instinct you
had which is the instinct my first
instinct even me mister keep your ego in
check
my very first instinct is like a little
bit of like a push back like oh that guy
and I want to lash out out right but
that's not the right answer you know cuz
it cuz well that's what you say is you
say yeah look at what they're doing so
you know what that is that's making
those attacks that's your own personal
ego that's my only your my own ego going
well that person just wants to get
promoted so if you can take a second you
can take a step back you can detach you
can put your ego in check and if you do
that then you say to yourself okay
here's what's here's the situation if we
remove the eagle here's the situation
this person is
working extra hard by the way this
person's appear so we're on the same
team this person is working extra hard
they're putting in extra effort they are
trying to shine and all those things all
those things are actually good for your
team right I got someone that's trying
to do a great job that's working harder
I'm actually happy mmm
I'm actually happy if there's a person
working harder on my team that's good if
there's a person that's trying to
outwork me and do a better job than me
that's actually awesome because now
we're gonna be a better team now mind
you any moment you let your ego slip
into this it's it turns into a nightmare
it's not good you don't like it you're
offended that someone's trying to work
harder than you but if you keep your ego
in check then that's good you realize
that it's good and I'll tell you
something else and this is work and what
I answered this question I said for this
person to outwork me he's gonna have a
hard time he's gonna have a hard time
out working because I'm here to win -
and that is a little bit of my ego mmm
but that mean that egos being a positive
thing cuz I'm oh you're gonna step up
your game guess what I'm gonna do step
up my game I'm not gonna undermine you
that would be negative that would be my
you go causing a problem but if I go oh
you're stepping up his game echo showing
up it at 6 o'clock in the morning
instead of instead of 6:10 oh and I'm
and I'm coming in at 6:05 guess what
guess what I'm coming in tomorrow
no 4:30 but you're right sorry I do I
just do a little more so now now we're
both a little bit more prepared now we
got some good competitiveness going on
that's good it's good for the team so
you this other person this other person
that step in at the game trying to do a
good job is actually awesome because
it's gonna make me step up my game and
I'm gonna tell you right now that person
is they have a hard time out working me
they have a hard time bring it I'm
actually fired up I'm actually getting
fired up right now like I'm getting I'm
starting like I'm
I might attack you right now just to see
what's up so that's good
now here's years worth the second ego
scenario that you have to get under
control what if that person steps up
their game I step up my game they end up
they actually do end up outshine me they
actually do end up getting the big
promotion mmm then what do I do
do I get better do I get jealous do I
get mad do I now start to undermine them
and spread rumors about no actually if
somebody if somebody outworked me mm-hmm
and outperformed me and then got
promoted
good for them that is awesome
credit they get a credit you're done
good son you're done good and there's
nothing wrong with that and what I am
gonna do is instead of being bitter and
mad and jealous and all those things
instead I'm actually gonna put my ego
out of the picture and say what actually
happened where did this person perform
better than me and how I how can I
support them how can I learn some
lessons from this and how can I become
better so the next time there is an
opportunity I do get promoted you
wouldn't think that that question is
about your own personal ego from the
beginning now it's easy to see looking
back yeah but from the beginning it's
like hey what do you do how do you
handle this situation when someone's
trying to outwork you now shine you and
they're trying to get promoted that
sounds like an interpersonal
relationship question is not the
question about ego which is which is
something we always need to pay
attention to so as I was thinking again
once again jock alive was kind of like
you went to two Jocko lives is that
correct yes
they weren't really a podcast they
weren't really a QA they weren't they
were just sort of a there were a little
bit of everything right a little bit of
a little bit of stories a little bit of
lessons a little bit of yeah a little
bit of everything yeah so I did get some
questions though that first one was one
of those general questions
and now as I started thinking about the
questions and how a lot of them related
to ego
another question that I got that was
actually another important question the
question was again something along the
lines of and I'm sure we can go back and
and pull the recording yes but here's
the other thing is some of these
questions that I got asked I got asked
like the same similar question so I'm
paraphrasing what this other question
was but this one the question was
something along the lines of hey listen
Jocko I know that keeping the ego in
check is an important principle I read
about it extreme ownership you talk
about it all the time got to be humble
but at my company ego is a huge problem
how do I get my company to start
promoting the ideal of humility and how
do I get them to recognize that ego is
such a big problem now this is a really
good question once again because you can
imagine what this individuals right like
you know you're at a company where
there's a lot of egos going on and all
of a sudden you have a little moment of
enlightenment you realize that ego is
causing you a lot of problems so you
start putting your own ego in check and
then you go how this is working I'm
doing better I'm coordinating better I'm
working in my interpersonal
relationships with the other people on
the team are better my relationships
with people on other teams are better
we're getting more done because our
relationships are better I'm putting the
team and the mission above myself that
means the team in the mission are doing
better that's great so you realize all
this stuff and then you say okay well
how do I start to spread the word how do
I get other people to do this and this
is a tricky question right it's a tricky
thing because if some if like let's say
your team has you see that ego is a
problem and you sit him down and go
listen guys you're you're all you all
got big egos and that's the problem I
mean you're gonna run in to level 9
defensiveness you're actually gonna it's
actually go beyond offensiveness they're
gonna start attacking you now it's gonna
happen you got all these crazy egos
they're gonna gang up there likes unite
they'll put their egos aside for a split
seconds that can unite against you so
you can't confront them and and once
again
are there certain relationships that you
could have with someone where I go and
if let's say you and me and you had Abby
go and put you and I were really tighten
I said hey man you letting you go get in
the way of this sure that kid that that
is a possibility that is a very rare
occurrence most of the people that you
work with on a regular basis you don't
have that tight of a relationship the
other thing is when someone has a big
ego that's not the type of person that's
open to those kind of criticisms anyways
so it's like there's two two hurdles
that you have to overcome number one
your relationship isn't usually that
good at number two they have a big ego
which is part of the problem and that's
what makes the problem hard to attack
mm-hmm so what are you gonna do in in I
gotta throw this one more little thing
when people talk about the you know how
if someone say put put wouldn't it be
better if you could just talk to him
wouldn't it be better if you just you
know put down on some bullet eyes list
and said hey here's the things that your
ego usually problems at your girl's
problem causing look I get it and it
isn't it great to have direct
conversations isn't it great if I can
just sit you down if you if echo if you
and I have this mind meld where you just
know a hundred percent looking out for
you and you're open to great like if we
have that that's in an ideal world
that's great mmm-hmm that's great golf
clap it's great the problem is it
doesn't exist very often and confronting
someone that has an ego about the Ricoh
can often just exacerbate the problem
yeah so here's what you do instead of
self identifying the problem and
pointing the fingers at other people
which by the way is placing blame which
is a problem so instead of doing that
what we're gonna do is start pulling the
thread on some of the problems that
we're having on the team so for instance
this group over here needs some help on
their part of the project but no one's
helping them what's going on if you
start to pull the thread on that you'll
find at the end of that thread they'll
be hanging some egos whether it's the
ego or the person that doesn't want to
ask for help whether it's the ego of the
other person that doesn't want to give
help because they think they need to do
their own job that's all I'm not okay
I'm not doing that
mm-hmm so you pull the thread and at the
end you'll find these little egos
hanging and then what you do is you just
expose them and you say what do you
think the root of the problem isn't you
start pulling that thread and you get to
a point where someone says you can
finally have an open conversation where
you say where someone finally says we
know I I guess I I guess I could use
some help you just discovered it so
that's like a cover and move situation
right if the cover and move isn't
happening and it isn't happening because
of egos if you pull the thread you'll
get to the end of the thread and it will
be attached to someone you go in most
cases is there a possibility that it's
like hey this group doesn't know what
the other groups don't yeah absolutely
those are but those are easy problems to
solve because we can just pull the
thread we find at the end oh we need to
we need better coordination between
these two teams cool there it is when
you pull the friend it comes out the the
little egos dangling on the end of it
then you go okay let's expose these and
let's try and ask questions to figure
out and get people to realize what
they're looking at hmm you want them to
come to that conclusion that's the trick
yeah that's the maneuver is to get them
to come to conclusion and they might
never verbalize it but they go yeah in
their mind they're like I guess I didn't
want to ask for help because my egos on
the way so there's one you know if you
got people that are taking aren't
keeping things simple just go through
the laws of combat simple make people
are making the plans too complex and yet
they keep doing it and there when it
when you go and say hey you know these
plans seem like they're really complex
and of course they say something like
hey that I don't think everyone
understood the plan
seem to get seemed kind of complex and
the person says people need to pay more
attention when I'm briefing and you pull
on that right the frontline troops they
need more detail because they otherwise
they're gonna screw up that's why it's
so complex like okay let's look at
what's really happening what's really
happening is I've created a plan that I
won't give up because my ego is too big
right when you pull that thread and you
go listen - hey the the frontline troops
don't understand what to do it seems
like that could be a real problem
mm-hmm and and maybe and there's nothing
you give them a little out you give me a
little out like you know maybe we just
need to back it off a little bit so that
they can understand it maybe they're not
as smart as Eagle massage because it's
fine you know what fine I'll simplify it
boom and in the meantime you've given
them a little indication look if you
confront them that's what I'm saying
it's hard for people who want to play
the long game here because the short
game is it you're you're you think
you're so smart your plan to do complex
and you're sticking with them could
you've got a big ego how's that gonna
work out
he's not gonna work out good can it work
out 4% of the time yes
the other the other 96% of the time you
get a defensive person that's now
accusing other people it's take the
indirect and play the long game take the
reading direct attack and play the
longer
prioritize and execute okay why is that
failing because again this question is
egos a problem so where does the ego
manifest as a problem it can manifest as
a problem in prioritize and execute
because if someone's got a big ego and
they're not getting things done and they
go I can get it done because their ego
thinks they can do anything right or
prioritize connect execute ego can be a
problem if you have a project and I have
a project and you need help and your
project is actually more important and I
should give you resources but instead of
like my initiative just as important
that goes is yeah which is just my ego I
should look at it and say okay you know
what you should be the priority mm-hmm
and another good one is yeah well it's
just what I just said like hey I'm not
gonna give up why should I have to give
my resources to act all those are mine
no actually what's them what's the
biggest priority
okay put my ego aside Echo's priority is
actually bigger than mine I'm gonna give
him four of my people so that he can get
the job done so when you pull the thread
on this and you say well hey hey why is
it jakka why is it you don't want to
give people to Eko I'm like well you
know what if something else comes up
well if something else comes up you can
get back well you know that they gotta
learn to respect the chain of command
well there's still work for you they'll
just be loaned over to Eko whoa
you see I'm saying yes it's just ego ego
ego so these are the kind of problems
that manifest themselves inside of a
company wrapped around ego mm-hmm and
decentralized command you can have the
same thing happen with decentralized
command how does the ego cause a problem
with decentralized command it's like
this hey I noticed that um you know you
seem to be making all the decisions and
the folks out in the field don't really
have the opportunity to kind of make
calls why is that I'm the only one that
has the experience to do this they don't
have the skill that I have right so
there's all these reasons that that's
one of those are ego problems right and
and by the way if it's if it's not an
ego problem then then then I say oh you
know what because I haven't really
trained the guys well enough and I'm
gonna you know what you're right I've
been making way too many detailed
decisions for the guys out in the field
I need to get down there make sure they
know what's going on train them better
so that I can back off cool that's a
person that's got the rego check the
person that's like I'm the only one that
can do this like no you can't you know
you're not and if you are you're wrong
because right now you got three people
working for you what happens when you
have eight you're gonna go around the
field in all these different locations
to make every single decision no you
can't
so get your ego under control realize
that you're not the only one that can do
this job
and train your people properly again
that's a direct assault probably gonna
cause problems instead if we just pull
the thread on it hey what's going on it
seems like your folks down the field
don't have a lot of authority well you
know they don't experience oh okay you
it's kind of cumbersome though like them
reaching back to you all the time to
make these decisions it is but you know
I'm the one that really knows how to do
it huh I mean what happens if you know
you're sick or you know you someone's
got to you know have communications with
them do you think it would be a good
idea you know since you have so much
knowledge and experience to maybe pass
that on to some of the other people oh
yeah okay cool let's make that happen
and then obviously ego can absolutely
manifest itself when it comes to taking
ownership I mean all day long right what
other that project failed what happened
would my subordinates don't know don't
want to step up okay so therefore why
what why are your subordinates taking
ownership cuz they don't even know what
ownership is didn't want to take
ownership okay so it's not your fault
no okay well what can we do to help them
mm-hmm pull the string and you at the
bottom the person will see it's the rego
they might not admit it but they'll see
it and then they can start to make
adjustments now look
can any of these situations escalate in
a point where in direct indirect in
direct indirect doesn't work and
eventually you say you know what well I
gotta go I gotta sit echo down and say
listen here's what I think is the root
of the problem the root of the problem
is you think you're the only one that
knows how to do this and in thinking
that you're not training to be like I
might have to get that direct it does
happen we prefer to use the minimum
force required required when it comes to
leadership just like being a bouncer yes
sir right it's not hey the guy's a
little out of line hit him in the head
with a boy
Jack no it's like hey hey sir you know I
think you've had enough for tonight okay
can you come with me that's minimum
force regard if the guy says okay cool
it's problem solved if he's if he sees
you I'm not going anywhere okay well we
have to escalate it's the same thing
here but don't start with the direct
attack mm-hmm just like you don't Club
the person out of the gate I think it's
a slapjack I'm not sure okay that's what
you're talk about that yeah as their
thing yeah yeah a blackjack yeah
blackjack yeah did you guys not use a
those that's silly I think those are
illegal to that illegal yeah yeah the
flapjack one guy had one yeah but yeah
very illegal so we don't want to
escalate straight to the blackjack or
even a slapjack even if anyone's using a
slapjack I think it's called a slap yeah
okay I'm not sure point remains I dig it
fairly confident you're wrong but not
100% yeah I'm like I'm like you know in
someone you know when you're pretty
confident about something that somebody
just throws a little randomness into the
soup and it makes you question yeah yeah
that's how I feel right now yeah that's
real confident with a little bit of
questions in it makes you feel any
better that's my everyday life so that's
the answer to this question is really
pulling the thread on the problem to
reveal the root of the problem which
you're gonna see is eco and then it's
there for the people hopefully to see it
to recognize it - possibly admit it
maybe not give them an out where they
can actually make an adjustment without
taking the owners of the Eagle because
that's ok yeah we're trying to win right
we're trying to let the team win we're
not trying to we're not yet what my goal
is not to make you admit it because you
know what that is that's my ego oh yeah
sure yeah it's got a big yeah get him to
a minute that's not my goal my goal is
to make you make better decisions as a
leader so that we win as a team yeah so
that's what we're
that's what we're trying to do here it's
really interesting that how you laid
that out because used to do that to me
no probably still do but it was less
about the ego I think anyway and maybe
it's all the same maybe at the end of
the it's all the same skating you're
trying to dancer right so explain to me
how I would do this to you do with the
excuses okay so like if something didn't
get done or can't get done or I think
it's too hard and really most of the
time if I'm remembering correctly it was
at the end of day this is what it was it
was like I'm too lazy or whatever you
know so it always be like this excuse
like well you know that's this or that's
that and then you'd have all these just
like how you're saying and I and it it
made me remember this because your tone
how you're like kind of saying those
little that's the same things with me
like no simple just like well just here
here's the solution to that problem
right here because there's all these
little excuses that you make you know
like oh I didn't really have time
because I had to do this and you'd be
like okay then you just do this you know
and that'll solve that particular
problem you didn't have this big
comprehensive plan to solve in my life
problem you're like okay for every
excuse oh and make you just have the
little solve you know the problem or the
solution to it and I'd be like man and
meanwhile you're getting backed into
this corner or the string is just
getting pulled like every with every
pool it was laziness oh yeah like I just
was too lazy or I'm just like stuck in
this routine or whatever and then it's
so it could in a way be like okay that's
just my ego just thinking that the way
that's not the way I do things kind of
thing and and think if I were to used a
different tone I think if I would have
just said that's good you're lazy oh
yeah yeah you just being lazy Aiko yeah
you'd been like do you even know what it
takes to make one of these things you
don't know me and then all of a sudden
we and what does that do to our
relationship yeah and what does that do
to to to the final product
yeah yeah right now you're doing
something against your will sustained
stain on it yeah fully in the a yeah if
you would have just been like hey you're
lazy this is what my mind would have
went to this belief this actually
way it's true but it doesn't like get
anyone anywhere where if you would be
like you're lazy I would have thought
and maybe even said that it's not that
I'm lazy it's just you're just this
crazy hard worker who have these
standards that are unreasonable for a
normal person and I'm just a normal
person excuse me
you know kind of an attitude that's what
I would go to rather than if you like
the way how you always do it is like you
pull the string or you just sort of you
don't know it's interesting to us when
I'm doing that I'm not doing that
like okay I got here's my next move on
that go yeah actually what I'm doing
it's like well you know you say well we
can't I can't make a video because it's
gonna take me too long to get through
the the raw edits and I go you know say
like well you know if you want just get
you you know hire someone to do those
raw edits for you would that work you
know what I mean oh I'm asking you a
legitimate question oh yeah maybe I
kinda know the answer I mean I suspect I
know the answer but it's not it's not
just hey I I'm setting you up I'm
legitimately pulling the thread you know
and the answer might be it is impossible
to get this project done but when I say
well you could hire someone to do those
right that's an in you go okay well even
if I hire someone how am I going to
transfer all this data and I go well if
you want what couldn't you get an
external hard drive and and just
physically give it to him yeah and you'd
say well these are actual situations no
no no just for the riff I don't know the
realm of video well the main the one
that I remember the easiest is like with
training like you'll be hey we're
training at 4:30 but I train during the
day most evening not in the evening then
you'll be like oh yeah a train at 4:30
I'm like well you know and I have all
these reasons and then you like you kind
of just chip away at all these reasons
like oh here's the solution to that is
solution that is a solution that's like
man I just that's just like my routine I
just gotta admit it you know like I and
but I don't get to train you guys as
often you know kind of thing but it's
like yeah you expose you pull the string
to expose just like the little
the little excuses Chuck so hold the
thread reveal the problem don't confront
if you can help it and people will start
to recognize what the problem is I mean
this is assuming you're working with
this well doesn't want this one problem
with this and that is if the person has
a giant ego that this is the hardest
thing for them to admit right so they
might not admit it but they'll see it
they'll behave differently and by the
way one of the good ways to to use
someone's ego against themselves is when
you say something along the lines of you
know man it's gonna look good if this
gets done right you know what I'm saying
and they think oh cool I'm gonna do this
I'm gonna make this adjustment just so
it gets done just so my ego can get just
so I can win yeah that would say that
use the word win because every time like
use the word win and any time what I'd
be thinking like okay if I didn't win
whatever you know what's left you lost
yeah no matter what excuse you make you
lost so if you put if you put the shed
light on like use that word and be like
hey this will make you win and you're
like hell yeah but at the same time the
vacuum mind like basically if we don't
solve these problems or whatever I lose
I want that so it's like extra motivate
the it's the winning at all cost thing
and so the winning at all costs I wrote
like a little section and it was a part
of a one of the special releases on
Barnes and Nobles version of dichotomy a
leadership was this thing winning at all
costs and it's and then someone posted
and I had I had said it before right and
someone posted a clip of me saying this
idea of winning at all costs and it's
the way that I talk about it it's kind
of a trick anyways because I go through
this thing about what is leadership and
leadership is this leadership to that
and I said what leadership is to me is
winning at all costs and somebody put
that probably you put a clip up of me
saying that and somebody said of course
someone's like that's the kind of person
that will run people over and blah blah
blah like it was like gave a negative
things right
but what they don't realize is what the
rest of that clip says and what the rest
of that whole idea of winning at all
costs is what I'll do it want to win it
all costs is totally subordinate my ego
help other people support them give them
what they need and put my foot put the
team and the mission above myself cuz
the moat that's how I'm gonna win at all
costs so winning at all cost doesn't
mean I'm stepping on other people it
means of actually lifting other people
up that's what it means so if you can
use that you know if I say hey echo man
look we need to win and you know if
we're gonna win the only way to win is
if you can learn how to work with Jim
otherwise we lose and you're like you
know what because I'm a winner I'll work
with Jim cool it's a first step and this
was kind of related to a question that
I've got we haven't done a Q&A in a long
time and this is kind of a partial Q&A
sure I don't know it's just some topics
but anyways we got one of these
questions hit it yes
chuckle what do you tell someone who has
been passed over for a military
promotion they deserved could you
address this yep so part of it is what
we just talked about what do you do when
you get passed over cool why did
something and it's also covered in I
think there's the wall I know there's a
literal chapter inside leadership
strategy and tactics which is what to do
when you're when you don't get promoted
that's that's the actual name of the
chapter when you're not chosen page 160
boom there it is when you are not chosen
and we covered it on the podcast so what
you do is you go and you say hey boss I
know there's opportunities get promoted
I know I didn't get promoted I know
there must be some shortfalls that I
have can you help me indicate what those
sort of Falls are cool so that's that's
and I'll just give a factual there's the
officer commissioning program that I got
picked up for mm-hmm
it was called the seamen to Admiral
program it was a highly selective
program they took 50 sailors from the
entire Navy
and there's 250,000 something people
sailors in the Navy they took fifty and
the first year that I put in for it I
did not get selected I got actually I
got selected as an alternate mm-hmm
which was as they say almost worse yeah
because you don't you know like you get
nothing you get to smell it yeah you get
to smell it you don't get to touch it
you don't get to taste it so it was not
good well it was good because I was like
okay I'm close but so but I didn't get
it I didn't get it
and what did I do assessed and said what
can I do better and worked harder and
the next year I got it mmm so if you
don't get promoted because you deserved
it maybe you didn't deserve it and if
you did deserve it you'll get it next
time
and instead of saying you deserved it
why not look at it and say okay what did
I not do to make myself the best
absolute best candidate that they could
not question needed to get this
promotion mmm
instead we're saying I deserved it
someone else got what is that doing
blaming the boss blaming in the
selection process blaming all these
other things that you cannot control but
if you take ownership of it and saying
you know what okay I didn't get promoted
there must be some things that I can do
better
there's the answer
mm-hmm own it ask give us give me some
feedback please or do I need to make
this happen and then implement now this
this there was this other topic that I
kind of wanted to bring up that was from
once again it was from jock alive and
and there was a young woman and again
this this goes to the kind of variety of
different people that were coming up
Jocko lives were all over the place so
this this young woman asked a question
that was kind of like how do you pan and
I can't when you're at the live events
there's light shining in your eyes so
you're not really a hundred percent sure
you don't get it it's not like you're
not seeing the person face to face so
I'm kind of looking out into the light
I'm seeing this frame of a young
woman and she asked something along the
lines of you know how do you handle when
there's people that are trying to pull
you down and and and you know pick you
apart mmm
and I said well what do you do and she's
like I'm in school and I said what
school and she's in high school and I
said what grade and she said I'm a
freshman and I said okay so you're
getting bullied right because
essentially that's what that's what she
was saying right I'm getting poked it
picked on I got people trying to drag me
down well you know what that's called
that's called bullying I said so you're
getting bullied and she said yes getting
bullied so I said I said you know I
thought about it for a second I said
well I've got some bad news and I've got
some good news and I'm gonna start with
the bad news the bad news is that people
can be mean and they can be mean for a
variety of reasons they can be mean
because they're insecure they can be
mean because they're bullied themselves
they can be mean because they're unhappy
they can be mean because they're scared
to be vulnerable so they put up that
front they might be suffering and
jealous and have no self-esteem it's the
way some people are and there's some
people that are just evil that get joy
out of putting other people down so
there's all those kind of people exist
and they especially exist inside of
immature people in high school so that's
the bad news and then I said but the
good news is high school is not life and
when I said that it was actually funny
when I said that like people started
clapping because everyone in that
knew that it was true and that reminded
me of another conversation that I've
been having with people lately about
about some about ecosystems something
I've called eco systems so little eco
systems in the world that people get
caught up in and they get caught trying
to get to the top hierarchy of some
little eco system somewhere and look I
get it
you know I get it Jordan Jordan Peterson
was trying to ascend the top of our
dominance hierarchy be the best you can
I totally get that mm-hmm absolutely but
we there's there can be a problem with
this from multiple angles the world is
filled with these little eco systems and
high school is one of them remember the
little high school ecosystem there's
someone that's popular there's someone
that's you know there's all these little
feet there's this ecosystem there and
high school this is something you know
you you look at a high school kid and
you you try and explain to them that
once you left high school no one really
cares right correct if you care about it
deeply you're actually uncle Rico right
that's running around say when I was in
high school this and when I was in high
school that but here's the problem and
this is one of the reasons when I wrote
way the warrior kid the first one one of
the things that triggered me to write it
was you know here I was at work
war going on big real legitimate crazy
problems and and dynasties and dynamics
to figure out like things are going on
and I'd come home and like my one of my
kids would be sad that they got called
the name mm-hmm or sad that they got a
low grade on a test or whatever and I
would be thinking like I I had a moment
of clarity where I thought I can't
believe they're I can't believe they're
sad about this who cares and I realized
oh yeah
idiot choco yeah that thing that's going
on in their world is their whole world
it's the Eco to see it's their entire
their entire world is in that one
ecosystem yeah so it's hard for people
to realize that their ecosystem that
they're in is not the whole world it's
the same thing with when you start
getting to college and I've got two kids
in college now you know this whole
ecosystem around first getting into
college and once you get to college when
you know where you're gonna get your MBA
where are you doing your internship
there's this whole thing right and once
again if you step outside that ecosystem
into just the normal world no one
actually cares about where you got your
degree yeah not no one because there's a
little peep there's a group of people
inside that ecosystem that they way they
go where'd you get your MBA Oh where'd
you study you know and there's people I
care about that there's other people
that literally do not care at all yeah
and I meet incredibly like from that
perspective I mean incredibly successful
business leaders all the time that don't
have their MBA and went to some state
school in Iowa
I got props the other day from someone
from Iowa that said whenever you think
of that state number yes from Iowa some
state school and I whatever some little
Community College in Nebraska and they
go out in world and dominate so but
that's not important we know that that
happens look and there's people that go
to Ivy League schools and get and they
do great too but what I'm saying is they
get in this little ecosystem where where
the what they're actually trying to do
is climb to the top of that ecosystem
only for the sake of climbing to the top
of that ecosystem not how it measures
into the greater world what kind of car
do you have
there's an ecosystem you can get wrapped
up in you know I've got of my Porsche is
better than your Porsche right there's
people that are into that and there's
other people that I do not care at all
at all
what about our little ecosystems we're
right jiu-jitsu has a own little
ecosystem you know you know what I'm
saying there's a little ecosystem who's
who what the podcast were old yeah has
an ecosystem so all these things and
those are just things that that you and
I are actually actively in right we do
jujitsu and we have a podcast so we
could jump into like where you add on
the hierarchy of these ecosystems and
again Jordan I get it
we're trying to we're trying to go up
the hierarchy I get it but you have to
be able to put that in check cuz why are
you doing that what is driving you if
it's if what's driving you to ascend
that hierarchy is because it's gonna
make it you better and the people around
you better that's good if you're doing
it for your own ego though that's a
problem mm-hmm
that's where it becomes a problem the
guess what the jobs or the companies the
industries
they get created there's sort of the
jobs that get created by companies and
industries they have their own little
ecosystem right about I work here I work
there I will I ran this region like you
can see it it's an ecosystem that exists
the SEAL Teams is a freaking ecosystem
and everyone's in there going like okay
where you add on the ecosystem where did
you we know how many deployments have
you done where did you deployed you went
what schools have you been to there's a
little ecosystem that people are trying
to get up and it's and I get it there's
some positive to that right because
you're trying to do better trying to
work harder that's good then there's
there's thing the bar scene you probably
can relate to this better than me
there's an ecosystem of the clubs yes
and who's the owner and who's the
manager and who's the GM and who's the
head door guy yeah and who comes in your
club
oh who you're gonna let in the club yeah
music scene real estate there's this
ecosystems everywhere and so this is the
point that I guess I'm getting to and
where it ties back into this young
female that asked this question when you
what you have to do is realize that in
most of these cases when you step
outside of that little ecosystem no one
cares about that ecosystem
no one cares mmm no one cares if I was
to tell my mom hey mom I got my black
belt in jujitsu 2005 hey mom I got my
black belt in jujitsu she well you know
what would you know what she would say
Oh congratulations know what she's
thinking that I'm in a strip mall doing
karate somewhere you know what I mean
yeah that's what she's thinking she
doesn't care at all
she doesn't care at all mm-hmm
your Porsche that you told me about I
can introduce you to many people that
think if you spent more than $5,000 on a
vehicle you're an idiot
never mind a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars in fact if you ever hear me brag
about a vehicle the vehicle that I brag
about probably the most is my 1997 Dodge
Grand Caravan that's the one I brag
about the most mm-hmm so when you step
outside the ecosystem of cool cars
people literally don't do not care the
the music scene oh I know this recording
artist I know oh and I'm going to this
studio it's like no one cares so my
point in saying this is if you find
yourself distraught about your failure
inside some random ecosystem then
remember that if you can detach and you
can step outside that ecosystem you're
gonna realize that that ecosystem in
most cases doesn't even matter at all it
doesn't matter at all detached this is
something that once again at jockle live
shows this came up and we talked about
detachment I talk about detachment or
one of the things look detachment is a
great tool as a leader to have because
it allows you to take a step
I can see what's going on right clearly
it's a powerful tool but you combine
that aspect of detachment to this other
aspect of detachment when when we've
talked about people that get caught in a
bad mental headspace and I don't know if
I want to use the word depression
because I'm not a psychologist and I've
never really had this depression so I
can't really speak about it from that
angle but to say that people get caught
in a rut that happens and I've talked
about that idea like let's say okay when
you win if you lose someone right
someone that you know dies and you get
put into that rut and the way I've
described it before is like there's a
storm cloud all around your head and no
matter which direction you look you see
storm cloud and anyone that's on the
outside and this is what I've said
anyone that's on the outside look and go
oh man you're just surrounded by the
storm if you if you step over here
you're gonna get away from that there's
a light at the end of the tunnel but
from their perspective they don't see it
at all if you can detach if you can take
a step back from your own head you can
actually see the end of the storm clouds
and you can see that you can get your
way out of this rut that you're in now
people ask me about how to detach and I
talked about it leadership strategy and
tactics but I'm gonna take a little bit
further think about this so here's a
couple things and actually the reason
that I I start I used to kind of look at
it like hey it's real simple right hey
take a step back just take a step back
take a breath right you know look around
in fact relax look around and make a
call was what I wrote about an extreme
ownership when it comes to detached like
relax look around make a call that's
detachment the the first time I really
broke it down to try and give people
some more specific instructions was on
the warrior kid podcast because you know
a little kid would say
get mad I start to lose my temper when
I'm wrestling or I start to lose my
temper when I'm in class and little
Billie's keeps poking me in the back of
the head how do I not lose my temper
well what they need to do is detach so I
said listen take a step back so I
thought about what I kind of do take a
step back and one of the things I said
was lift your chin up hmm lift your chin
up and now now when you start to think I
said talking about why do I even do that
what what benefit does that have well if
you think about when you take a step
back and you actually lift up your chin
think about what it does to your vision
all of a sudden your vision is elevated
it's an elevated one inch but it's
elevated and you now have a physical new
perspective you have a physically new
perspective of what's going on by taking
a step back lifting your chin up well
the other thing it makes you do is if
you put your head back it like makes you
open up your chest and open up your
lungs and it makes you take a breath
which I used to attribute this to when
you're on the radio look one of the
reasons that I was like thought about
detaching and something that I caught
realized was a good tools you never want
to sound panicked on the radio and the
SEAL Teams so before you key up that
microphone to say something you go
whether you say alright guys we need to
move towards that north building instead
of no you don't do that so when you when
you lift your chin up you you know you
kind of take a breath it forces you to
kind of take a breath and the other this
is the coolest thing that I kind of
connected this at Chaco Life and the
reason I connected it because I was up
like right now we're sitting down and
we're kind of we're kind of stuck in
this position so I jock alive I had like
a like a lavalier microphone on Saul's
up and moving around and getting crazy
so as I was going through this I was
acting out the the process of detaching
so I take a step back I lift up my chin
and I made this connection I was like
think about the posture that you have
when you're getting ready to get into a
fight it's literally the opposite you
lift up your hands you duck you tuck
your chin down you roll your shoulders
forward to protect yourself and you are
getting in this defensive posture which
is not an open posture for seeing what's
going on
right it's a focused posture when you
take a step back you lift up your chin
you're actually making yourself
physically vulnerable and what you're
also doing is you're so you're opening
yourself up to threats but you're
opening up your mind to see a different
perspective so that is incredibly
important it's an incredibly important
first step in training yourself how to
detach from all this chaos that's going
on from the mayhem of a leadership
situation to detaching from your own
ecosystem that you're wrapped up in that
you think is important that no one cares
about no one cares about outside that
stupid Club you're in no one cares no
one cares outside the the the the the 38
people that are involved in your glee
club they've got you paranoid and
freaking out no one cares so if you can
take a step back and you can see that
and finally if you can take a step back
from your own brain and you can kind of
assess that cloud that you're caught in
you'll see that that cloud is not
infinite and you'll see that there's a
way out mm-hmm which is important very
important
yeah that that and that can get more
strong and powerful that that lure
that's sucking like keeping you in your
ecosystem one it's like part of your
routine you know because it kind of
feeds into your identity a lot of times
like in jiu-jitsu super strong like were
you you know if you get tapped out by a
guy who never taps you out it's a bribe
that'll follow you all the way home
with your fat and you know your family
you're thinking it can you know if your
mind is just sucked in because it's kind
of part of your identity or whatever but
yeah if you can just step back look
around kind of detach from that you're
like Brad no one cares like very
literally every other environment there
you go it in life nobody cares that guy
tap no one care thing you'd even dude
you did to don't unless you've got a
spring into action at the door so
there's no yeah they're like what was
that yeah just work magic
exactly it is probably never gonna
happen by the way as far as probability
goes I think and I think when you're
younger I mean obviously when you're
younger you get you get caught up in
these ecosystems and this what's scary
is this can be the downfall of a kid
right you get caught up in the drug
ecosystem you get caught up in the booze
ecosystem you get caught up in the in
the what is it
delinquency like hey I'm gonna cause
problem hey you know what do boys do boy
this is another thing that came out of
chocolate like boys are trying to prove
themselves to their friends and to
themselves how tough they are how cool
they are so when what whatever whatever
little ecosystem has their own little
cool meters in it right and sometimes
that cool meter is you know I'm getting
so I'm gonna drink this fifth a jack
yeah or I'm gonna smoke this or whatever
like that's a they want to move up in
that ecosystem and so they do stuff that
outside outside that ecosystem people
hey that's actually one of the dumbest
things I've ever heard
yeah but you can't see that yeah the
party scene is a big one I mean there's
a difference between like getting caught
in the ecosystem of the party scene and
then
going down the spiral of like drugs and
addiction cuz a lot of time the diction
is like that's just like a chemical
payoff you get and then that chemical
payoff you you'd want so much it's just
more of a payoff than literally anything
else in life and then it just compounds
but the ecosystem that introduces you to
the payoff that ends up being an
addiction that ends up ruining your life
yes so yeah like the party scene for
example it's like yeah okay did you go
to this party oh you didn't go to there
you're kind of less than kind of thing
you know oh I'm at all the parties
you're the kind of up you know up there
in that little ecosystem then you go to
those parties and you got a function at
the party right so you can't just we go
to the party like now I'm not drinking
one of they're like you know you're not
fitting in the party at all so you're
gonna fit in so you're gonna do that you
know you're obviously gonna drink and
then what if they're doing some some
other drugs in the back room the cool
room the fee IP room the secret room or
whatever if you're not part of that
you're sort of your the minion you're
not one of the Fiat P so you one of the
VIPs you've got a function yeah there's
a whole peer pressure thing wrapped up
inside the ecosystem oh yeah that's like
the primary driver of the ecosystem oh
yeah yeah because even the positive
things that go where you get where you
were you getting your MBA yeah like so
they got all these 18 well don't know 19
whatever 20 21 year old college kids are
like wait read me hate where you gonna
get your MBA where you where you're
playing where you probably where you're
fine
oh yeah and if you're not applying to
the whatever then you're a little bit
down on the ecosystem and you know what
no one cares well you can't say no one
cares because there are people that are
going hey we want to get someone from
this school cool mmm fine that's a
little tiny subset of the same ecosystem
yeah and but if you're talking about
like yeah if you're talking about people
outside the ecosystem no they don't care
they don't care full care if you're
capable and then so a lot of times if
you're like oh you got a MBA from here
okay that's an established kit you know
capable there gonna be you know put out
some good students yeah or some good
trained people or whatever then there's
that but it's not like they don't care
about what you care about right now you
know the fact that you got it from here
doesn't mean you're like awesome the
thing that's so hard for kids is they
just can't see outside the ecosystem is
their world yeah and so introducing
people to this concept that there are in
fact these random
ecosystems that actually no one cares
about is a positive thing yeah don't get
caught up in them especially not
negative ones but you know what there's
also people take positive ecosystems and
turn them negative because they start
getting the ego involved like like
that's right jiu-jitsu is totally
positive ecosystem hey we're just here
to Train we're here to have fun and all
of a sudden it turns into drama
because we haven't talked too much about
the jiu-jitsu drama and I'll be honest
with you one of the reasons that we
don't talk a lot about the jiu-jitsu
drama is probably because we don't deal
with it a lot because we have a very
open door policy at our gym and we're
just kind of cool and we just want to
change it too and want everyone else to
change you too and I think San Diego at
large is very similar to that because
they're just do Jitsu everywhere so we
all just kind of know each other and so
I think that has something to do with it
and I also think there's less jujitsu
drama now than there was 10 years ago
yeah you know 10 years ago is like
that's my student yeah you went to my
other you went to someone else's Academy
cool you're out of my Academy forever I
banish you it's right there was that
kind of drama is there still that kind
of drama there probably is song but not
as bad as it used to be yeah but they
took a positive ecosystem and turned it
into negative ecosystem yeah yeah I
would imagine that's kind of everything
like even okay so my nephew gets good
grades really good grades but he takes
it you know how like certain students
they take their grades like super
seriously they get one bag or they're
late for school like Brownwood if to me
if let's say my mom brought me to school
but if you have to explain to me that
you weren't worried about being late
when you're 10 it's unnecessary go on
wildly unnecessary for them for the for
the people we'll let you explain how
much you didn't care about being late
even as a child go up especially for
school put it this way if I was late had
to get a tardy slip breath the
connection between that and like grades
and success in life was literally
non-existent
so it let's say the boss I would say
maybe that's how you ended up showing up
late all the time oh my god did you very
possible so if my parents were my mom or
dad or whatever if they're driving me to
school and they were running late well
IIT me caring was literally at a zero I
didn't care at all it was like cool I
don't have to spend as much time you
know at school and not that I was bad at
school or anything I'm just saying like
right I don't care about that stuff at
all anyway my point is some people are
the opposite some people are like I
can't be late for school it's like
school is like everything in their
grades and stuff like that that's
positive that's really good actually but
it can get out of hand it's the thing is
yeah out of hand
yeah you get kids freaked out your kids
cheating cheating freaking out freaking
out looking weird drugs too like yeah
like a lot or whatever yeah all those
things all those things are bad and all
of them are related to the fact that
they think that that ecosystem is the
whole world everything yeah and let's be
honest I mean how much of that ecosystem
affect you you didn't even show up for
school all right well now you're here
king of the podcast ecosystem Michael
Charles oh yeah so everyone should do
that yeah I think if if you take and not
not that I'm like the epitome of or the
poster child for great parenting advice
nothing like this but I think like the
more you take your kids and see other
stuff outside of school kind of their
mind is gonna not just be attached to
like this school scenario you know well
that's a whole debate you know that you
could have like but here's a real simple
question does your kid if your kid goes
is your kid ten years older in fifth
grade and they don't want to miss school
so they don't go with you to collect
whatever
Kawai they don't go experience something
like that I guarantee you that the
experience in kawaii is way more
beneficial educationally spiritually
yeah athletically then hey they missed
three days of it a half
yeah bring the math book bring it yeah
really yeah for sure and that's just
kawaii either like you know I mean even
just going to see what you do at work or
whatever yeah like I used to take my kid
to you know go in training sites yeah
are you kidding me best thing ever oh
yeah and I'm not even necessarily saying
have a miss school to see this stuff I'm
necessarily saying that but I'm just
saying like everything isn't like okay
go home do homework it's like everything
if you if you create this idea that
school is everything in their head then
you know it's they're gonna tend to
think that I think but you know if you
see you know let them see other places
where you work or whatever whether in
the weekends or summertime whatever you
know you just see other things they
realize okay school isn't everything you
know and what you're really showing them
is this is one ecosystem in the world
it's called school it's an important one
yeah but there's no reason to get crazy
there's other ecosystems out there that
are also cool and good all right keep
detached don't get stuck in ecosystems
next question I am stuck in a prolonged
period of things not going my way
professionally or socially all that
really is going on well is my time
management still even after having owned
up to my part in getting here I still
seem stuck in a failure loop okay
so what's being addressed here is the
prolonged period of things not going
away and and we know that a key part of
getting out of a rut like this or a
failure loop is taking ownership of
those failures of those problems that's
very important but guess what that alone
doesn't solve them at all just saying I
didn't get promoted okay it was my fault
peer
that doesn't solve the fact that you
didn't get promoted I'm not getting
called back to do this other contracting
job it's my fault does that mean you get
called back no it doesn't mean anything
taking the ownership means that you
actually have to identify the problem
you know you're responsible for it and
then you actually have to solve the
problem that's what you have to do just
taking ownership of the problem doesn't
make it go away if you take ownership of
the problem you have to take ownership
of finding a solution and then you have
to take ownership of implementing that
solution so this is real straightforward
now there's one little tiny part that I
want to point out which you may or may
not have noticed echo Charles and I'm
gonna point it out so pay attention to
this last sentence in the question still
even after having owned up to my part in
getting here and I still seem stuck in a
failure a failure loop what you notice
about that echo Charles if there's
another part a hole maybe even parts
yeah right there's multiple facets of
the world that are conspiring yeah to
keep you in this failure loop yeah it's
like that tone of when someone's like
hey I did my part I did my job hands up
you know kind of thing don't I do my job
that's not my job the other parts that
are more implied a guest another you can
uncover in the mode it's like there's
this other job that someone else is
sorta part so this is the thing and this
is what this is what makes this very
challenging is this idea that like but
how could I possibly control this or
that how can I possibly take ownership
of the fact now this is a weak one how
can I possibly take ownership of the
fact that my boss is an idiot and fired
me mm-hmm
how can that be my fault that he didn't
see how good I was right okay we see
what's going on there you obviously
aren't being introspective and taking a
look and saying okay this is obviously
my fault here
what I need to change so there's things
like that where you go look you're just
not it was same thing with relationships
right she broke up with me how can I own
that well maybe you look at yourself and
you see how you acted as a partner in
that relationship and if you just want
to look at that person say it was her
fault she was crazy and she would it was
her fault she didn't understand how
awesome I was yeah that's not that's
that you need to take ownership of your
own behavior why did she think that now
you do get to these things where you
have no control
so God asked a question a guy said my I
lost my girlfriend to opiate overdose
yet she died how do I take ownership of
that and so I expanded that question
because that's one of those things where
you look at you know when you look at
you go how can you take ownership of
that this person did so much drugs and
it wasn't like I like okay I don't know
the specifics of the situation but if
you know I'm doing everything I can to
help my girlfriend and then one day I
come home and she's od'd she's dead okay
how can I say I wasn't even there right
and I let's just say I'd done everything
take her to rehab done all this stuff
and as far as I could tell she was clean
and behind my back without telling me at
least she did this right so it's almost
like okay that's as much separation as I
can get how do you take ownership in a
situation like that and so here's what I
went on to say to this guy I said this
might seem like a unique situation but
it's not because there's things that
occur in our lives that we actually
don't have any control over for instance
most horrible you your family member
someone you know gets cancer gets a
horrible
terminal disease how do you take
ownership of that and the answer is in
these cases when things that are truly
beyond your control occur what you take
ownership of is how you respond to them
that's that's what you take ownership
how do you respond to you lose your
girlfriend to drugs your kid gets cancer
you get cancer something you get this
horrible disease how do you respond to
that that's what you can take ownership
of and that's what you have to take
ownership of so I guess my point in
saying that is yes there are absolutely
things that you cannot control and what
you can control is your reaction to them
when they unfold that makes sense what
scares me about this guy is he's saying
he's owned up to his part but that means
he's blaming someone else and I can the
amount of things that we have zero
control over is very small so many
things if we look at ourselves and say
what could I do better what could I do
different how can I make an adjustment
here how can I adapt to the way this
boss is how can I adapt to the way this
girl is that I'm trying to have a
relationship and by the way that might
not be the best relationship maybe
that's part of what you need to do is
take ownership of the fact that you're
addicted to this that's what he's saying
this guy here saying he's so social on
some assume he's got some problems with
his female friends right or friends in
general
hey you didn't want to want to come
watch UFC not really I'm buying guys
that's okay we're gonna go to you know
some mmm home is they're watching it by
myself I can't believe that you know
what's wrong with everyone else
no actually what's wrong with me mm-hmm
now truth be told I don't want to watch
UFC with anybody else generally I want
to sit alone and watch the fights no
commentary no questions don't ask me a
question sure what was that move no I'm
watching the fight everyone just be
quiet a lot of times some of us we like
to demonstrate
our professional knowledge of the
subject you know so answer here you need
to look at that the reason that you're
probably stuck in this loop continually
is because the things that you're
blaming on other people take ownership
of them and get them fixed take
ownership of them and get them fixed
take ownership and make some moves take
ownership and look what you can do
different that's what you have to do
next question in your recent book
leadership strategy and tactics you
mentioned establishing trustworthy
relationships with superiors you speak
of performance and compelling tasks you
stating tasks Oh completing tasks yes
performance and completing tests you
stated boss wants me to fill out some
extra paperwork I'll do it boss needs me
to cover a shift for someone else on the
team I've got it boss has a nasty low
reward mission that needs executing I'm
all over it
page 49 50 how does this separate you
from being a yes man especially when
being a yes man is looked upon so
negatively these days
what are your thoughts yes it was
actually maybe he hasn't gotten there
but there's a whole section in the book
that's called yes man yeah and why you
don't want to be a yes man because if
you're asked man you don't push back
when a situation requires there to be
pushback so so read a little bit more
but to make it quite simple
being a yes man is saying yes to
everything regardless of whether it's a
good idea or not building relationships
and establishing a good communication
and a good rapport with your superior is
totally different than being a yes-man
part of it is saying yes because if you
resist everything that they say to you
they don't really think they don't
really value your opinion they just know
that you're just a no man no we can't do
no camp there you're mr. negative mr.
yes-man is going to do whatever so what
you do is you say you
when you can some menial tasks
retirement some extra paperwork cool
I'll do it some some cover a shift for
someone else it's cool I got it I can do
those things those are easy they're not
impacting my team we're good
nasty low reward project that needs to
get done cool I got it let's go bring it
bring it I'm here it's gonna help the
team awesome oh you want me to do
something that's gonna negatively affect
the team and put massive amounts of
capital at jeopardy or putting people in
risk or put safety at risk you I'm gonna
do that hold on boss no boss and I
wouldn't be just no boss I'm not doing
it but I go through the book how you
actually approach those situations so
that you're not a yes-man so when you
win it when there's comes a situation
that unfolds that you actually need to
say no you can say no and it gets
listened to that's the difference
leadership strategy and tactics get some
kind of you know so many of the
questions in leadership strategy and
tactics there's so many the answers that
I give in there are based on the answer
questions that I get asked all the time
and so really so many of the questions
that I'm hearing now I have the answer
and leadership strategy and tactics I'm
trying not to just say well refer to the
book yes 9800 refer to the book page 64
I'm trying not to do that but just FYI
for anyone that's out there it's in
there alright next question I was hoping
for some guy in a kind of a similar
question here but gone yes I was hoping
for some guy I'm gonna cut you off again
no I just did that for fun anyway I was
hoping for some guidance on how to play
the game with a situation at work I work
in in an aerospace machine shop from
doing this apprenticeship to be a
machinist mechanist machinist this means
that I'm supposed to get specific types
of on-the-job training with a 7 set
number of hours each with a set number
of hours each ok i go to school once and
we're gonna read roll
big huh no no no are you in Romanian
discern kind of what is that saying at
the end of the day anyway set numbers
arms normally you get a little sensitive
if you make some mistake I'm just gonna
take this from the top bow my whole life
isn't one big mistake so whatever it's
an expression you know I go to school
once a week to supplement it the problem
is they won't give me any work that
fills those designations I'm doing my
best at the menial paperwork they've had
had me on for a while without complaint
it's a real problem though when I'm
paying out of pocket for the tuition
that comes with the program every month
spent not getting required required
training adds to the five years it takes
to complete the OJT on-the-job training
how do I get them to move me where I'm
supposed to be do I just continue to do
the best at what they give me and accept
the loss of time and money yes so you
remember the book that I caught me of
leadership humble not passive so this
guy's being humble playing the game hey
I'll do the menial paperwork I'll I'll
work these extra hours I'll do these
things that don't really help me he's
playing he's playing the game and he's
being humble right but he's also it
sounds like being passive meaning he
needs to up his assertiveness to say hey
listen hey hey boss
I just want to let you know when I put
together this spreadsheet of what I'm
actually gonna get accomplished and
here's the things that I want to get
done and I know I'm trying to knock out
all the stuff and I'm here to support
the team but I also need to get these
things done can you help me get these
things scheduled so that I can be more
value to you and the team mm-hmm so yeah
you build the relationship through
playing the game you build the
relationship by giving support wherever
you can but at the same time that
doesn't mean that you just roll over and
never stand up for yourself yeah that's
not what we're talking about here the
difference is you're not building a
relationship just so you can take care
of yourself right that's different that
means I'm just looking out for me you're
building a relationship so that you can
move down the right path which by the
way is gonna make you more a bigger
asset to the team so it's a win-win
situation make sure you build that
relationship and then talk to them about
what it is you're trying
get done why you're trying to get it
done and that way we move forward down
the path and by the way if they're like
shut up and just do this paperwork or
shut up we're not gonna help you cool
maybe we need to find a place that has a
little bit better opportunity for me and
I'll start to float that out there
mmm-hmm humble not passive remember long
time ago I'd say you you you this use
this word efficient be more efficient
rather than make it easier for me you
know like even though they're
essentially the same thing in certain
circumstances where it's like oh yeah
this will make it easier for me to
become an asset kind of thing but for
whatever reason maybe like just the way
that sounds well yeah it sounds like
you're looking out for yourself and yeah
yeah but if you say it'll get me to be a
more valuable asset in a more efficient
way who could say no that that not
because of what company doesn't want
efficiency huh no we want to take the
hard road we want to do things that
don't make any sense yeah we want to do
things inefficiently no yes efficiency
is important not only in jiu-jitsu you
know not only in judo but in business
and in life all right so there's one
more little topic that I wanted to bring
up and really it's it's another question
that I got it at jockle life and I got
this question or a version of this
question a couple of different times and
they all they all a couple different
versions this question but the same
question and the question is it's
something like this something along the
lines of I've been pretty successful at
this point in my life and I'm having
trouble finding the motivation to take
it to the next level so you know it's
like people I say oh so you you know you
met decent money yep but the couple yeah
we're doing really well and you're
working out yep I'm healthy yep I'm good
and your family's taking care of you
having a good time with my family but
you're not able to like
get the extra work out you're not you
know you're skipping some days you're
not eating great you're not making the
calls that you need to make you're not
expanding your eyes and that's what's
going on right and so that's what we're
getting at we get someone that's sort of
in a good spot kind of across the board
right kind of in a good spot across the
board and so I'd kind of established
that fact that they're in a good spot
across the board mm-hmm and then I'd say
but it sounds like you're in a good spot
across the board
are you happy with that and are you
comfortable with where you're at and the
answer would be no and then I'd say are
you sure and then it's a young Chiron
you know I want to do more and then I
said that's a lie that's a lie that's a
lie because if you really weren't happy
and you really wanted to improve your
health even more and you really wanted
to improve your financial situation more
and you really wanted to just broadly
improve your life then you wouldn't have
any problem at all finding the
discipline the discipline would actually
find you that's where I'm at now that
you want to know why people like oh you
don't see pretty much you want to know
why cuz this one finds me because I know
I will I know I can do more and I want
to do more and I know I'm not happy
where I'm at and comfortable where I'm
at so if you're telling yourself no I'm
not happy where you're at then I'm gonna
tell you that's actually a lie you are
comfortable you are comfortable because
if you weren't comfortable then it would
drive you the discipline would show up
now this is where I kind of I I kind of
have to go a little bit deeper so what I
just said if you tell yourself the
truth then you'll find discipline the
framework of discipline is the truth the
framework of discipline is the truth and
I have to go and I didn't do a good job
when I got asked this question I didn't
do a good job of connecting all the dots
because it actually is one level deeper
it's one level deeper and it looks like
this if you're saying that you can't
find discipline and I'm telling you it's
because that's because you are
comfortable where you're at that is also
a lie
that is also a lie
look telling yourself that you don't
need to get out of bed in the morning
telling you something you don't really
need to workout or you don't need to go
harder or you don't need to do more in
your job or be more discipline in the
way that you live if you tell yourself
those things that's actually a lie
because the fact of the matter is think
about this the fact the matter is that's
you're not comfortable you're not happy
you're not okay with where you're out
because that's why you're asking this
question right now you're asking this
question because you know you can do
more you know you can be more and that's
the truth that's the truth and it eats
you up and it makes you ask these
questions ask the question to me and ask
the question to yourself and the answer
is the truth you know it I know it we
all know it that the framework of
discipline is the truth
if you tell yourself the truth the real
truth the absolute categorical
unconditional unabated an unmerciful
truth if you do that you will find
discipline discipline equals freedom
discipline is rooted in the truth the
truth will set you free
and what does that calculus work out to
discipline equals freedom and I think
that's all I've got for tonight so echo
Charles this seems like we want the
truth over here yes so that we can do
more and we can be more is there
anything that you know of that helps
reveal the truth to us yes jiu jitsu max
never lie when you're when you're when
you make eye contact with that guy who's
a little bit better than you maybe
bigger maybe we'll give you a scenario
where you got to put out more effort
then maybe you want to that day when you
make eye contact and then you like look
away
everyone sees that oh you mean pre-roll
pre-roll oh there's like a scenario that
could unfold but we haven't connected
yeah I contact for the role yep
it's like avoidance avoidance yeah
everybody knows that's one of one of the
many attempted lies that we sort of try
to you know perpetuate in ourselves like
I'm good right that's what people kind
of they want to be good at jujitsu I
think you know on the mats
you know Akbar sure of course yeah he's
really sick jiu-jitsu and he's super
like hard to roll
just cuz he's strong and wiry and
athletic and freakin gold Jim doesn't
stop yeah but I have like an unwritten
rule with him no matter what 100 percent
if if either one of us wants to roll we
roll yeah it doesn't matter what's going
on if one of us wants to roll we roll
yeah and and most of the time he wants
to roll I don't and I roll them every
day yeah yeah that's how and in that
kind I mean let's face it that like you
have mixed emotions about those kinda
because you see them in your like cuz
you have it in your head like you can't
not roll with that person I have that
with Noah where if he's there it's like
it's on its and hammies like I don't
know if man he's been kind of working me
recently
yeah so it's like oh man I see him I'm
like I know this is gonna be like a hard
roll but I can't not roll with them like
that defeating the whole purpose of my
existence here right now if I don't roll
with them for sure he's the same way
he's coming at you the whole time he's
freaking awesome at jujitsu he's in good
shape he's strong he's got just got it
he's he's gonna bring it yeah he's gotta
be use like that's the way it is yeah
we're gonna roll yeah no Akbar like
these guys that it's like okay if they
weren't here it'd be it would be an
easier day regardless yeah but not
everyone's like that you know and
actually there can be guys who are like
even actually better than you but you
roll with a minute's like it's not this
huge like it's not that like you know
it's like that's just different
tightness yeah yeah but the lie that we
can tell ourselves even though you're
the only one you're lying to everyone
ever can see what you're doing when
you'd like to avoid that yeah
now there are situations that unfold
then this is the one that I do so let's
say I have an injury yes right
legitimate injury I will let's say a
normal day for me is like okay I'm gonna
do eight rounds you know eight six
minute rounds cool that's normal like
that's a good role for me I had a good
time you know whatever takes an hour
whatever this is a minute rest so maybe
not but but anyways if I'm if I'm
injured sometimes I got to be like okay
I can only do four rounds because then
it's just ah
yeah dad I'm gonna reinsure something
stupid and I just I'm like hey what I
tried to tell people beforehand so that
way I'm not being that guy but if you
want to roll with me now is the time cuz
in four rolls maybe five so you know
then I'm gonna then I'm gonna call it
yeah so it does happen and I guess the
reason that I'm saying that is just to
be like well I'm gonna roll no matter
what if you're injured and like you know
the deal like when you're injured you
have it you can you can you can get
lucky for like three four rolls and like
okay I didn't tweak anything we're good
and it didn't get worse well that fourth
fifth roll now your sixth roll you're
tired you're giving giving up a little
bit more and all of a sudden that's when
you get hurt mm-hm
so just a just a little tale of caution
yes big-time and you know one it you
know it's easy kind of like when we're
just sitting here you know not in the
situation like oh yeah you just you just
work around the injury and if you gotta
get caught in a submission that's how
you know no it's not a submission that
you're gonna get that's easy you hope
that someone if you've got a sore elbow
you hope that what hurts you is Oh
someone puts an arm lock and you got all
tap early right that's what you hope it
is yeah what you don't hope it is is
you're rolling and turning and your arm
gets caught in a bad spot and now you
reinjure it yeah there's no tapping from
that that's just another injury yeah so
though I mean what I had in my head was
like where you know your knee or
whatever would everyone rib whenever and
you're like I'm just gonna go like kind
of little lighter you know right then
you roll run one round with like no or
something go light no way Ben I'm and
it's you can consciously be going oh
yeah I'm gonna go light but start
rolling yeah just see how much you can
remember to go light when you're you
know whatever sure you always say to me
like when you do a good move to me and
you say uh yeah yeah you see that's a
big victory for you
get my sense of urgency to increase and
it's like the biggest W oh yeah cuz
you're just so good and you say it to me
too
well I don't say that it's a big W but I
do say and I recognize your auntie
anyway oh when you're in the moment
whether you can control it fully or not
or whatever I would say you just
decrease the chance of you staying safe
as time goes on
yes you just see that's just like the
numbers yeah like just like odds odds
the odds are yeah I made it through four
rounds I'm okay great well I'm walking
off the map right now right so that's
like the opposite of a lie you're like
being so it's so truthful with yourself
you're like hey you know and you're in
you're doing the right thing the lie
comes when you're like you're not
injured
you just may be not feeling up to it
maybe you're hungover I don't know maybe
that you put in a person and then you
say well you know I'm this or I'm sick
or I'm this and you say that excuse or
whatever to yourself and then like you
avoid the hot rolls yeah I had Wes like
I was training I was deep into some
rounds and Wes's and Wes was on the
other mat he comes over and wes is a
beast too like him he's just strong it's
jiu-jitsu it's awesome and he every time
it's gonna be a gut check and I'm like
sitting up against the wall I'm done and
he's like hey you want to get one and I
was like and I said no mm-hmm you know I
was like no and then and then I was like
brah hey they're like 30 seconds went by
and I was like I bro sorry that's just
weak like in there cuz I wasn't done yet
yeah I knew I wasn't done there's times
where I've been like hey no like I can't
roll like I've got it I'm no I'm done
for the night
it's not smart for me to roll I need to
have discipline this more than anything
else right because you know you when
you're injured you're there it's like
you want a role so bad you feel like a
caged animal you just wanted to get on
the mats of justice yeah pretty much any
time you're there and you're not ruling
injury it's sourced man working in my
case you know filming whatever ya know I
mean that's just how but yeah but again
that's like the opposite
well I like your your your truth is is
very how I say strong like you don't
like the lie like hits you hard when you
begin to lie to yourself you know yeah
but some people they can just roll with
it but everyone sees what you're doing
everybody you know or they go Stein is
built every 10 seconds you know like all
you know back to me yeah you're trying
to perpetuate so much yeah
but the mats they don't lie so that's
why that's why we think jiu-jitsu is a
positive thing sure I think so it does
expose our truth or maintain our truth
it's a good at your system and I think
so you gotta be careful like all
ecosystems but in that ecosystem this is
what we do care about okay we have yeah
come on we all check it out like whoa
what you put it this way we don't want
to be walking around with a second-rate
key that's made in wherever not here
yeah yes no we don't what do you want
your D to say look I trained you Jitsu I
work hard and I support this country and
its workers yes that's what I want my G
to say you know there's only one key
that says that oh there's only one key
that says that yeah and that's the
origin key and I think we all know that
you know so yes the question what what
do I get one I do jujitsu when I start
you Jitsu when I compete in dude in
jujitsu you get an origin key yes you
get an origin rash guard for the noogie
scenarios that unfold and then since you
can't wear Aggie and a rash guard in
public unless you're John Danaher big
Z's is represent that rash is these
little representing the rash guard super
hardcore
as far as I know but no he's definitely
so legit we need to send him some rash
cards anyways if you're not John Danaher
and you're gonna go out you don't really
want to wear gay pants and a rash guard
you can get other clothing from origin
main such as t-shirts jeans mm-hm
sweatshirts
hoodies hoodies what were you gonna say
I think sweatshirts and hoodies kind of
covers it covers okay what were you
gonna say you say jeans yeah jeans 68
Delta 68 are those out yet working on it
if you're working on you working on it
well good I actually told Pete let's put
and I don't like to do this but let's do
the pre-order thing mm-hmm
so we can actually get the demand signal
because people are demanding the Delta
68 yeah because I talked them up because
they are truly the greatest things I've
ever put on my legs also joggers those
are not the greatest things I put them
on you know but they're not really for
me no I'm not a joggers kind of guy cuz
you don't well yeah I mean you know
fashionably speaking uh yeah that's not
you comfort you know that's kind of down
there on your list of priorities so I
get it right now those are just two
things that I'm not Roast super
consumable although oddly enough the
comfort of the Delta 68 is one of the
things that makes them is very epic yeah
it's just like the cherry on top if you
came to John alive I was wearing Delta
68 yes if you see me in public and I'm
wearing jeans they're Delta 68 J again
there you go or Jin main dot-com is
where also supplements these are
important supplements joints for your
joint supplements for your joints that's
important trial if you can be the
strongest guy in the world your
shoulders not working let me ask you
this is this jacked up so a guy hit me
up on social media and was like hey
you're old how do you you know how do
you maintain like how do you do this and
you know I is one of those things where
I was like well do I just tell them like
straight up man if you're not on joint
warfare and krill oil you're just wrong
like step number one get on join warfare
and krill oil seriously super krill
joint warfare that's what you want to do
now the thing that I told them also is
very consistent yeah right I'm I don't
I'm not one of those guys that takes
three weeks off from doing anything and
then jumps back into the zoo to squat
like no I'm working out for all
practical purposes I'm working out every
single day
now is there occasions where life gets
in the way sure yep that's what it's
called a day off that's why I don't take
voluntary days off but I'm telling you
if you want to maintain like the
activity at a high level and you're an
older person I mean I'm only 48 I feel
like I'm 21 or 22 maybe 27 how about
that sure
but joint warfare and krill oil those
are the supplements that you're
specifically talking about right now so
I can't recommend them strongly enough
and I should have just told that guy
listen be consistent work out do a good
job warm up and take krill oil enjoy
warfare but then you feel like I'm just
yes you don't even is selling this guy's
stuff like bro this is it yeah so I
actually did him a disservice yeah
because that's true when you go like
everyday and consistent your body sorted
you know for lack of a better way of
putting it in as far as details go but
your buddies just used to it but at the
same time yeah you know like your joints
are taking a beating if you're pushing
hard which I am which yeah I mean why
wouldn't you sure I mean I guess maybe
there's under some circumstance that's
okay but if you're pushing hard yeah
your joints gonna be like kind of taking
some of the brunt yeah sure you know so
yeah if your judge can see in the game
Brett it's like yeah well no more
important if your joints can't stay in
the game you're out of the game yes
that's the problem yeah that's the one
it's like hey you can be big and strong
and your joints don't work it doesn't
matter you're only as strong as your
weakest link
make your weakest link your strongest
link joint wore Frank royal discipline
go discipline powder form
awesome if you need a can of a tasty
beverage that's actually good for you
you give yourself some discipline go
ready to deploy yes sir drink with ya we
prefer to play over here I think I
understand also milk protein in the form
of a dessert additional protein I know
we're eating steak I get it it's true
it's good but you want the dessert with
some additional protein some to increase
and improve your protein synthesis just
got hit to that one it's like when
there's protein okay so I was one of the
guys who who one of the many of us who
you know what you know what an anabolic
window is yeah it's like after you
workout you get a certain amount of time
yeah yeah you gotta eat the protein and
pea cake it in because that's when your
body like kind of wants to take it in if
you miss that window it doesn't take as
much in mmm so apparently that's not as
much of a thing okay
from what I'm bro scientist before
there's been controversy in the bro
science world yeah I know man just just
a shift really very night a paradigm
shift row science world so interesting
from someone that has a doctorate in bro
science echo Charles you know I'm always
sustainable so what is the point uh so
we can drink milk any time all at 9:48
at night when I'm like you know what I
want dessert right now cool I'm gonna
smoke yeah yeah basically yes so it's
more about out the protein rolling
around in your system generally speaking
and you know when your body needs
protein to rebuild muscle boom you got
some protein aren't in there whether you
take it in 20 minutes after you lift or
if you know you just sort of taking it
in throughout the day same thing goes
for your children they can take in
protein at any time they can also taking
poison sugar but don't give them that
give them the protein the good stuff or
your kid milk and then get yourself some
chocolate white tea by the way which is
as echo Charlie likes to point out
organic it is certified
hi I'm Jocko willing organic certified
tea salesman yeah
definitely who would have thought look
it's not about the organic it's about
having an 8,000 pound deadlift which is
100% guaranteed mmm double-blind
double-blind placebo yes did ya get some
and by the way all these items are
available right now at the Vitamin
Shoppe so you probably hopefully have a
vitamin shop near you you can just go
down there and pick up any of these
items that you want which is pretty
awesome
mmm go check it out by the way this
Friday February 8th in San Diego
California at the Vitamin Shoppe we're
gonna be there that Friday or Saturday
sorry Saturday Saturday February it's a
yeah it's Saturday February 8th we're
gonna be there a be there a lot it is
Saturday we're gonna be there maybe that
alive me you JP and Dakota Meyer Jack
savage no Jack savage is actual we'll be
there come on down and hang out and
people are like will you sign books yeah
I'll sign whatever you want I mean
within reason within reason I mean and
by that I only mean like I'm not signing
you know body parts body parts
yeah well motive like some dead body
parts I'm not gonna sign yeah so there
yeah it's good or domain.com yes or do
you mean calm for all this stuff
good stuff by the way also Chuck or the
store it's called Jocko store that's
where you can get the deaf core stuff
the discipline equals freedom stuff the
good quote unquote good stuff and when I
mean stuff that's t-shirts hoodies
lightweight and heavy rash guards more
rash guards representative of the path
directly well you did too I saw some
people on the podium representing
recently on that one yeah way to
represent no appreciate everyone that
represents the path big-time
oh yeah podcast and a deaf core
yes so you hum part ish yeah big time
but yeah our hats on there as well cool
stuff on there we like something get
something represent while you're on the
path Chaco store.com also subscribe to
podcasts if you haven't already we're
still we don't know if that's important
is it important it's important it's not
not important overall we're saying yes
it's important so do it
do subscribe if you want so good it's
beneficial you know if you're listening
you should subscribe yeah that's my
opinion
yes great Jennifer show on your IQ and
don't forget that we also have the
grounded podcast where we talk about
life jiu-jitsu we're looking like we're
probably to make some more of those in
the very near future
warrior kid podcasts that is the best
podcast that a child could listen to and
my biased may be am i right
absolutely and don't forget about
warrior kids soap and I am overjoyed to
inform you that we have a new soap out
from Irish Oaks ranch calm it's got anti
bacterial anti microbial right right
calm almost well anyways it's got really
good stuff if you're dirty
especially dirty in the tense of jujitsu
where you've got little creepy crawlies
trying to get into your skin then you
can get something that that we made
young Aidan and it's called killer soap
good Irish oh Transcom so you can get
yourself some killer soap and stay clean
also YouTube channel we have a YouTube
channel for the video version of this
podcast and some excerpts on there you
don't share these excerpts go ahead do
it if your boss needs to hear this don't
do it like that I'm just saying if you
sorted this [__] anyway
good stuff on there I think enhance the
stuff as well you can see Jaco and his
things are exploding things are catching
on fire sometimes yeah things are
cracking open
yeah in synchronicity in synchronization
with my words
yep and music cellos and whatnot yes
laughs haven't heard echoes enhanced
videos you may not know it echo is a
cello enthusiast I well you know every
time he plays me one of his videos when
the cello kicks it I gave him a look
anyway videos on there yes YouTube
channel yeah what's it called Jaco
podcast Jaco podcast called thorn we
also have something called psychological
warfare and I got a great piece of
information a great suggestion from
someone some trooper out there just made
a great suggestion the suggestion was
you talk about psychological warfare you
should describe it as a little
psychological hater as soon as I said it
I was like you get credit credit so yes
you need a little psychological hitter
to help you get over some moment of
weakness well guess what we got
something for you it's called
psychological warfare it's on iTunes
Google Play other mp3 platforms if you
need a visual hitter then go to flipside
canvas comm where it Dakota Meyer
speaking of is making visual
representations of the path that you can
hang on your wall on your ceiling in
your doorway keep you on the path that's
what you need to do got some books
leadership strategy and tactics the most
recent the answer to they answer to
every leadership question that I've been
asked on this podcast that I get asked
all the time so leadership strategy and
tactics Field Manual everyone that got
it thank you made it number one on a
bunch of different lists which was
awesome and I was super stoked it was
especially awesome if you're in the
literary ecosystem then you go a whole
number one everyone else doesn't care so
I'm kind of got one foot in that door
cuz there's a bunch of people that I
work with that are in the literary world
because that's what that's what it is
right you write a book you're in the
literary world yes
so that ecosystem sorry you guys even
though none of you care you all
propelled me to the number one in that
ecosystem that anyone that's outside a
little literary world doesn't care about
people say how do you stay humble guess
what no one cares about this stuff
that's how leadership strategy tactics
got a bunch of kids books away the
warrior kid one two and three miking the
Dragons for that little or kid
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
which people just take pictures of that
and just post just a picture of the
cover of the book which I'm always like
credit so leadership strategy and
tactics is Field Manual to the first
Field Manual was disappointing cause
real freedom Field Manual the audio
version of that is on iTunes Amazon
music Google Play and other mp3
platforms and then of course it all
started with extreme ownership and the
dichotomy of leadership which I wrote
with my brother Leif babban about the
lessons that we learned in combat and
how you can use them in business in life
we got EF online which is leadership
training online and what this is is a
supplement actually it doesn't even have
to be a supplement it could be the whole
meal if this is what you can do then you
want leadership training go to EF online
if you need it inside your company
inside your business inside your team
you can contact a salon front comm
that's my leadership consultancy
national front dot-com what we do is
solve the problems of through leadership
we got some musters coming up up we got
well all the ones that we've done is
sold out but ones that are coming up on
deck are Orlando Florida Dallas Texas
Phoenix Arizona and Phoenix Arizona go
to extreme ownership calm for those all
the events that we've ever done have
sold out so if you want to come go to
extreme ownership calm early so you can
get some and a last thing we now have EF
overwatch and EF Legion EF overwatch
aimed at exec
of leadership taking folks that were in
the military leaders senior leaders in
the military and placing them into
civilian companies so that they can help
that company move forward
that's our executive leadership
placement firm we also have EF Legion
which is font line troops and frontline
leaders so if you've been in the
military if you're a veteran and you
want to find your next mission if you're
a senior leader cool go to EF overwatch
if you're a junior leader go to EF
Legion and companies that are looking
for junior leaders or executive leaders
you can do the same thing
EF Legion comm or EF overwatch comm
these are people that understand the
principles that we teach and can apply
them inside your business and if you
have not heard enough of my exceedingly
slow talking and ludicrously serious
tone and you haven't had enough of
echoes marginally marginally applicable
metaphors you can't get enough of those
two things well guess what you can get
more we are available on the interwebs
on Twitter Instagram and on Daffy's a
POC echo is that echo Charles and I am
at Jocko willing into final word here
thank you all for listening to podcast a
podcast that exists thanks to your
support thanks for listening spreading
the word telling your friends thanks for
getting some deaf core or some origin
gear all of which supports this podcast
and of course thanks to all the service
members out there in uniform who protect
the very freedoms that make this podcast
possible also to our police and law
enforcement firefighters paramedics EMTs
dispatchers correctional officers Border
Patrol Secret Service all the first
responders and I saw a bunch of military
members I saw a bunch of first
responders at all the jockle lives and I
appreciate you coming out and I want to
say thank you for providing an
environment where
we can live our lives as we see fit and
to everyone else out there remember to
tell yourself the truth
remember to tell yourself the truth you
know what that means the truth is you
need to do more the truth is you need to
be more to reach your fullest maximum
capacity and capability as a human being
and if you tell yourself that truth you
will find discipline and if you find
discipline you will find freedom so do
not lie to yourself and instead get out
there and get after it and until next
time this is echo and Jocko out